the also there's a connection to what
you're doing that's different than
almost any other connection to food I
mean the only thing that's reasonably
close and it's pretty far off is when
you grow it yourself so if you grow your
own vegetables
you got a connection to that food but
that's the same it's not the same
connection as you get no because you're
just gonna send an arrow through an
animal you look at its eyes you're
looking at size but also that you know
how difficult it is and when you pull it
off there's this powerful connection
between you and that animal you earn and
you eat you earn it oh yeah and when you
eat it you feel that you earned it
I'm telling Joey out of it when Anthony
Bourdain came to my place he was still a
little squeamish with kill and stuff
even though he ate dead stuff on every
show and got his paycheck from eating
dead stuff he's a great man terrible
loss terrible loss and we talked about
it and I I shared my knowledge with him
I'm not I don't have an opinion it's an
animal it's dead
you either Revere it or you don't you
either utilize it with respect or you
pretend you didn't have anything to do
with it it's dead you're eating it you
should have been closer to the system
and the hunters fishermen and trappers
of this country still carry on the
definitive physics of spirituality that
the native and Aboriginal peoples called
the Great Spirit
hence the spirit of the wild the prayer
for the wild things but we're in a weird
place Ted with cities right right right
you were yeah but I mean you got lucky
and that your father was interested in
bow hunting and that it gave him an
escape which by the way it gives a lot
of veterans today a lot of veterans and
good friends of mine of finding the elta
great relief in bow hunting as a
discipline after combat life you talk to
a guy that shared many campfires with
those guys it's a trail last night great
transition for them it's consuming yes
fredbear uses the phrase coin the phrase
and I use it all the time it cleanses
the soul when you leave the pavement
when I leave the pavement and I make
that transition from modern concrete
jungle hand to hand
that City I because that's where my
rock-and-roll career is the ultimate and
you take that deep breath you literally
go back to the Year 100 highway nearby
and I know I can hear trucks off in the
distance and the train whistle which is
kind of titillated unto itself but when
I get in my swamp in Michigan or my
woods in Texas to quote Jimi Hendrix
ain't no life of nowhere I am the
aborigine it's me my resources and the
beasts and it's a it's a religious
experience it's the spirit that it
natives call it the great spirit thief
to consider the Buffalo there brother
and it is so consuming that I don't care
what kind of stress you could be going
through the ugliest divorce in the world
and I have you could be fighting against
people who don't think that America
should be first and you don't need
secure borders and and you don't need to
earn your own way you're able-bodied but
you want somebody else's income you're
just crazy [ __ ] and all of a sudden I
get out there and I'm telling you Joe
it's perfect yeah I'm I'm literally
intoxicated I'm I'm drunk I'm stoned
trying to pick up all the signals and I
do I do a pretty good job I've learned
over the years because I need that so
much to play my music like I play it
that it cleanses my soul and I've I've
been contacted since the 60s with vets
who have gone through just absolute
torture in their military careers and
when I get them at a campfire and we go
out and sit before the Sun comes up
I can't tell you how many times they've
cried because it's it's good again it
was a great morning